الاف الاسرائيليين سدوم داخل مطار بن
غوريون الدولي شرقا لابيب نافذه اسرائيل
على العالم
تتصاعد الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ضد خطه تعدها
حكومه اقصى اليمين يقول المتظاهرون انها
تسعى للانقلاب على جهاز القضاء وتقليص
صلاحيات المحكمه العليا وتحويل اسرائيل
الى دوله دينيه اصوليه ديكتاتوريه
اذا لم تنجح احتجاجاتنا فاننا مقبلون على
انقلاب على نظام الحكم لدينا وزراء
متطرفون يريدون تحويل اسرائيل الى دوله
اصوليه
الاحتجاجات العارمه اجبرت بنيامين تنياهو
على استقلال مروحيه للوصول الى مطار
الدولي حيث نقل الى هناك اجتماعه مع وزير
الدفاع الامريكي قبل ان يقلع الى ايطاليا
في زياره رسميه وقد اتهم خصومه السياسيين
بالعمل على اسقاط حكومته
المعارضه التي تريد جر الدوله الى فوضى
المعارضه تريد اسقاط حكومه انتخبت بشكل
ديمقراطي والتوجه الى الانتخابات السادسه
الاحتجاجات التي لم تخلو من اعتقالات
ومواجهات مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه تتخذ هذه
الايام منعطفا جديدا لاسيما مع تزايد
اعداد الداعين الى عصيان الاوامر العسكريه
بين ضباط وجنود في الجيش الاسرائيلي
معظمهم من سلاح الجو ووحدات النخبه كاشير
نحن نقول للحكومه عندما تتحول اسرائيل الى
دوله دكتاتوريه لن نخدم في الجيش ولن نخدم
هذه الديكتاتوريه هذا الموقف موجود ايضا
في صفوف الجيش النظامي تسميها الحكومه
اصلاحا وتصفها المعارضه بالانقلاب وان كان
الامر فان مواقف محايده تعتبرها خطه محكمه
وضعها بنيامين نتنياهو لانقاذ نفسه من
ملفات الفساد وتمهيد الارضيه لمنح الشرعيه
للوزراء حكومته المدانين بتهم جنائيه كلما
تقدمت الحكومه الاسرائيليه خطوه نحو تشريع
التغييرات القانونيه يزداد الحراك الشعبي
زخما وقوه ليس مؤكدا ان كانت هذه
الاحتجاجات ستنجح قريبا في حمل الحكومه
على التراجع عن خطتها لكن من الواضح انها
تعكس وجود شرخ عميق في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الجزيره من مطار بن غوريون الدولي شرقه
لابي